thank you everyone for coming so the
last session for today is about chatbots
and I'm going to talk about the past the
present and the future of chatbots a
little bit about me I am the founder and
CEO of a small start-up in Seattle
called to carry solutions and I'm also a
faculty member at Northeastern
University in Seattle teaching AI and
natural language processing related
courses my company is focused on
developing solutions for helping
computers to understand human language
more recently we're focused on
developing custom chat BOTS a little bit
of an overview about my talk I'm going
to start with a brief discussion of what
our chat BOTS how the chat BOTS evolved
why should we be excited about chat BOTS
now and some use cases of chat bots in
real life the internals of a chat bot
the most interesting piece is how do you
build your own chat BOTS and finally
where are we going from here the first
question what is a chat bot it's
basically a computer program that's
designed to simulate conversations with
human users so here's an example where
somebody types in reorders and the chat
bot knows the context of what you're
talking about they said well it looks
like your last order was this one
cappuccino extra hot extra large size
and the quantity was one and you have
two options they no no no cancel or
reorder that this is a very simple chat
bot but it's still very complex in the
backend because it understands context
of what you're talking about it knows
about time it's not presenting in order
that you ordered maybe a year ago this
is something that you did maybe five
minutes ago or 10 minutes ago - 20
minutes ago
so how did these chat BOTS
evolve the evolution was is very
interesting because it started with the
Turing test the Turing test was
developed in the 1950s by a person
called Alan Turing
and the idea was that this is a test
which would evaluate whether a computer
can be indistinguishable from a human
being it's it's something like this
if there's this person who sends two
packets to two different people or or
machines behind two doors this person
should should be able to or should not
be able to distinguish between which
reply came from a user or a human being
verses which reply came from a computer
and today we are at that stage where we
can simulate computers to act more and
more like humans by training them on all
these conversations millions and
millions of data sets which which are
actual human behavior so now we're
getting the question of for how long can
we can we pass the Turing test as
opposed to can we even really pass the
Turing test the other piece about how
chatbots came about is through question
answering there are these easier types
of questions like factoid questions
which are based on facts which means
questions like what when where if where
the answers are objective and these
answers can be retrieved or extracted
from things like Wikipedia pages where
if you ask the question well where was
Barack Obama born you have this answer
nicely placed in a table on the web page
on a Wikipedia page of Barack Obama then
there are more hard questions which we
are still struggling with and these are
basically the questions that break the
Turing test things like how to cook
lasagna well this is a procedural
step-by-step kind of an answer
you cannot just give it something like
boil boil your pasta and you're done you
need the entire list from start to
finish and you need maybe pictures the
second type of question which is more
interesting is how could you do that to
me
which as a human being we know the
answer is I'm sorry or something of that
sort but a computer could say well I
took the knife and I stuck it in your
back and then something else happened
which is a much more of
that kind of a step-by-step thing which
we don't want but it's very hard to
distinguish between these two different
types of questions the third the third
piece of how Chad Watts evolved is when
it came into mainstream of communication
and Men and mainstream devices in 2011 C
was became a part of iOS and iPhones and
it was a big deal to have a person like
thing to communicate with and ask
questions right there on your cell phone
you could look at weather and locations
and set up reminders and call people and
I was available to you back in 2011
another thing that happened in 2011 was
Watson by IBM competed in jeopardy and
it actually beat two human people who
were experts in their fields and experts
in jeopardy with the price of 1 million
dollars and that was a very big deal
because now we were at that stage and
it's a big deal for science that we can
actually compete we can actually make
computers compete with human beings for
answering questions today we are taking
that and helping businesses helping lots
of different industries to have to
simulate this company's conversations
and have human beings do much more
interesting tasks now here is a quick
demo of a Best Buy app where they have a
digital assistant and we wanted to ask
them a question about do you do price
match well there was nobody available to
chat right away online so we try the
digital assistant and it gave us an
answer from the FA cues and if you look
at the best buy a fake use on the
website there are thousands of them it's
really hard to maneuver your way through
all of that but getting this why do
you're talking to somebody and and them
asking you at the end of it does this
really help with your question really
have streamlined the entire process of
searching the web for your answer or
being on hold with a person and trying
to get your answer
or just screaming at your phone saying
representative representative so that
brings me to the next topic of why we
should be excited about chat box one of
the most important things is we can
outsource mundane and repetitive jobs to
computers customer service is handling a
lot of questions I mean if you're like
me you probably have called your bank a
couple of times to figure out where can
you find the account number or the
routing number on your account because
it's so it's hidden in a way that is
hard to heart to discover but that could
be easily automated by a chat bot and a
sidebar can tell you exactly how to find
it with screenshots and a bunch of other
things so it's a repetative question
that might be occurring 70% of the time
in the financial industry figuring out
which customers are disgruntled and
replying to them you can tell the tone
of a customer you can figure out the
urgency of a customer based on how they
write something how many capitals
they're using
and several other things to figure out
who has a higher priority and who does
not the upside of this is that humans
can focus on more interesting issues we
do not want to replace people because
people interaction is definitely not
replaceable but big and focus on
something where must with a much more
higher level of emotional and regular
intelligence is required digital
assistants are available instantaneously
you don't have to there's no downtime
except finish server crashes but even
then there are concurrence ease in place
and they perform specific tasks so if
you have a digital assistant for FA cues
with the example that I showed you
that's what it does it helps you with a
fake use and nothing else if you ask
that assistant about how do I save my
marriage or what's the meaning of life
it won't do a good job by that and you
should we shouldn't expect it to do a
good job of that another reason why chat
bots are a huge opportunity is that
one of the recent studies her credit to
Business Insider is that people like
communicating with other people as
opposed to communicating to everybody so
if you see the the yellow line it is
social networking apps and the red line
is messaging apps people like messaging
one-on-one significantly more than as
compared to networking or sharing with a
lot of other people so here is that
brings me to an example of real life use
cases so there is somebody who goes to a
website for a real estate chat bot and
the system says well how can I help you
and this person says I need to put in a
service request to have a leak in the
kitchen faucet fixed the system says I
can set that up for you how long has a
leak been going on this is interesting
because the system looks at the duration
when there is a leak you want to know
how long something's been going on to
determine the urgency of that leak it
started last night
well the system deemed it to be very
urgent and it said well I can have a
technician take a look at it within the
hour because if it's been happening
overnight it's probably a big deal do we
have your permission to enter the house
when no one is around yes and the person
the system scheduled that that this
visit around this leaks problem and
there are seven things going on in the
backend the system understands real
estate concepts it understands the
concept of leaking which is a big deal
it understands the concepts of urgencies
about what to do how early to schedule
how late to schedule it has connections
with individual people and in their
schedules and it's also performed a
scheduling concept another example is
for sensor data why is room two to one
so cold
looks like the temperature sensor is not
functioning of normal temperatures
recorded for the past three hours of
normal temperatures which means that
temperatures should usually be within a
certain range for human beings and if
it's not in that certain range there's
something wrong and it's probably the
sensor as opposed to the actual room
being very cold or very hot can you put
in a service ticket for it done this
request is in schedule and will be
performed at 4:45 p.m. on this specific
day with this specific person so the
system is doing all of this repetitive
and manual work for us and we don't need
to worry about doing that as human
beings so now comes to we come to the
more interesting parts of what are the
internals of a chat pod so when you're
designing your own chat bar there are
some basic considerations that you need
to focus on one is what is the core
tasks why do you think this task is
important and do you have data to
support it so for instance if 70% of
your web traffic asks these FAQ
questions number 100 to 150 we want a
chat bot to do really really well on
those questions and not bother about all
the other things in the world what is
the input data so the previous example
that I gave was it needed to be
connected to sensor data it needed to be
connected to scheduling of all the
customer service representatives and
bunch of other things so what is all of
that what are all of those inputs that
their chat bot needs to be connected to
what is the output do you want to change
a number on a spreadsheet do you want to
change a sensor do you want to you know
have sales projections will you be
working with sensitive data because if
that's true then you'll have to have
more barriers you have to create your
own server with extra extra protection
HIPAA compliance for medical data and
others for financial data and what kind
of natural language understanding do you
need do you need deep understanding do
you need some kind of shallow
understanding with just simple regular
expression
matching and finally the the interesting
question is do you want your chat bar to
appear human if it does not appear human
people don't want to interact with it
but if it appears to human it just seems
like ah this is this Ted was acting way
too smart I don't like it nobody knows
the meaning of life why are you and
trying to attempt it
here's roughly how chad watt
architecture should be we have input
text core NL u engine some tasks that we
want to perform and then goes computing
a solution and coming back to a finance
final response some things that we need
to consider how much context should a
chatbot remember from the past the leaky
faucet example that i gave if you have
that same leaky faucet thing for the
past year that this happened in the last
year it implies something else it means
that there might be plumbing issues in
the house
if this leaky faucet request was sent in
in the last five minutes you think well
it's a duplicate request let me flag it
as duplicate because this is already
handle so understanding that context is
pretty significant this is the exact
this is an example of a time-based
concert context but there are several
others that we can think about what type
of context should we remember so time is
one jokes and sense of humor probably
not review about given products maybe
maybe that's interesting what's the
purpose of the chat bot I already talked
about the Turing test but there are
several others like generic BOTS there's
so many out there that tell you the
weather they tell you the time or that
can navigate from location a to location
B and then there are specialized bots
that are few and far in between like a
retail bot for placing your orders or a
healthcare bot that can help you talk to
somebody when you really need to talk to
somebody
customer service spots which are coming
up significantly in a lot of different
areas UX design so here is an example of
subtle confirmation if somebody asked
was the weather in Toronto the
temperature in Toronto Canada
is three minus three degrees Celsius the
interesting thing is it did not look at
Toronto Ohio it looked at Toronto Canada
it changed the temperature from degrees
Fahrenheit degrees centigrade and it
confirmed that I'm telling you the
temperature for Toronto Canada now the
user can come back and say oh that's not
the Toronto that I was looking for in
which case your chat board can switch it
up again and tell you the temperature in
degrees Fahrenheit for that specific
location and this is a simple example
but it shows how how it's at board can
be customized so much to not only appear
human but not keep asking questions but
just present information and leave it up
to the user to interpret what they want
to personality do you want your child to
be funny and happy or do you want them
to have a much more serious personality
that has to be defined early on because
the language that you would use would
depend on what the personality of the
chopper is so the more most important in
the fun part of the talk is how do I
build my own self on a few things to
consider where do you want to host it
what kind of infrastructure do you want
do you want your child back to live on
flat only do you want people in your
company to use it do you want the world
to use it what what kind of NLP do you
want it's hard to get away from chat box
without natural language processing and
artificial intelligence and you can do
something very shallow like if you see
our words the word leek in any text flag
it as a and or give a specific reply but
then you know the world the word leaks
can be leaky cauldron from one of the
Harry Potter books which doesn't
represent a leak in in your house so
there are lots of things to think about
between the shallow and the deep NLP
deep is definitely something that's
required for more complex tasks can some
NLP be outsourced to an external API
there are a lot of api's out there which
I'll get into in in a second which
which can handle a lot of these tasks
these more complex tasks quick platforms
that we have facebook messenger slack
the top few one where can we host them
well if you are building your own chat
BOTS AWS Google Cloud are one of the
most popular ones pivotal and several
others are available as well some
advantages of using a pre-existing chat
platform there's already an existing
user base you can separate logic from
the infrastructure you can handle
sessions much better there's downtown
down time management and faster user
acquisition
here are some chat bot services that are
available with Python SDKs for us to use
and to build now these are just a small
snippet of it and with a few cases that
I've looked at there's several more
cases on a much more larger spreadsheet
for this specific thing and if you are
interested please feel free to email me
and I can send that to you I talked
about a couple of them and so that you
have a flavor of what each of them
offers chatter bot is a free to use API
on on github and it is trained on lots
of different conversations this person a
says something person B says something
else if he says hi it replies as hello
if we say howdy it replies that maybe
howdy or something else that's more
appropriate to howdy
it the conversation services for chatter
bot is to appear human as opposed to do
any task so if you go back to my
architecture that I presented it doesn't
it only focuses on the first purpose
input text and then there's output it
doesn't actually do NLU or any
understanding or performing any task the
one of the most popular ones is API dot
ai which is acquired by Google it has
some
language understanding for selected
verticals which means that it it it
works with a limited set of domains so
things like booking calculators contact
it has enough data that it has trained
on it that it can understand things that
are referring to shopping and things
that are referring to needles and things
that are referring to booking so if you
are building something which requires
any one of these there's no need for you
to build from scratch you can always use
this API to to handle the contacts part
of your chat bot or your calculator part
of your chat bot or several other things
it supports a large number of languages
which is also very interesting and very
very rare I was acquired by Google in
2016 and it also has the ability to
train new classifiers if you have your
own data if you want to train on
something more proprietary you could do
that and that data would as long as it's
not sensitive you can actually share
that data and train your own models
there's one drawback of using API dot AI
and that is it runs on a query based
thing a user has to initiate a chat as
opposed to a chat bot initiating a chat
now the interesting thing in that is
it's similar to querying a search engine
I ask a question the chat bot gives me a
response well sometimes responses are
much more complex and chat BOTS need to
ask follow-up questions like the leak
examples when did it happen where is the
location is there a puddle around it and
a bunch of other things which API dot AI
cannot do by itself and we need to add
more components in order to do that it
also doesn't understand context or
doesn't have that functionality of
context
the next thing motion AI it's a
flowchart based system where you can
build a flowchart of conversations and
it converse is based on how you have
designed your flowchart to be
they are focused on visually building
training and deploying Charcot's review
chat interfaces and flowcharts they have
some bot templates like the previous one
like the restaurant restaurant bot
survey but that adoption bought and so
on so it's a little more complicated
than than the previous one but they're
focused significantly on infrastructure
not a lot of NLP not a lot of machine
learning there is some so you might have
to take the core science piece of it
outside and use it for infrastructure to
create beautiful quads the third thing
which is probably the last one that I'm
going to talk about is which AI it is
they market themselves as natural
language for developers which means that
if you're a developer and if you want to
use any kind of NLP you can use this to
to build your chat BOTS the good thing
is there's lots of NLP support for
developers it's multilingual the core
functionality is limited and that's
that's an obvious thing and in only the
data that's freely available in the
world can be used to Train any kind of
model so if you're looking to build a
best part that's proprietary to your
company you would have to provide that
proprietary data flow chart based
conversation management and it's owned
by Facebook one of the things I wanted
to say is flow chart based conversations
are great if the user follows through
and answers exactly what the bot is
talking about but we don't think that
way you know how I was working with a
bot recently and they asked me for my
email address and I said I don't want to
share it right now and it replied saying
that doesn't sound like an email address
can you give me your email address and
that happened five times listen this is
not working and I said no thank you I
was polite I said several things I also
tried there spam detection system and I
said a not so polite word and they still
did not detect that this might be a
spammy user so there are several things
that we need to consider when we are
working with a flow chart based system
because
we are not wired that way and we need
our BOTS to accommodate that and make
sure that they switch around in
different pieces of the flowchart based
on what the human being is talking about
so what is missing chat BOTS need to be
experts in their fields we don't need to
know trivia about the world
unfortunately most chat BOTS that are
being used out there
no only trivia about the world and they
don't they are not experts in their
field a lot of people are working on
that like real estate BOTS or cosmetic
surgery but Finance sports a lot of
companies are coming up banks are coming
up with their own financial BOTS to make
transactions and several other things a
lot of services try to build a one fits
all solution but examples like API dot
AI or motion dot AI cannot accommodate
for all different types of solutions you
need very focused solutions to solve
your specific problem so the solution is
to build your own BOTS build a custom
chat BOTS have not used freely available
chat BOTS for everything but use it for
specific things like scheduling or
calendar or calculator for instance if
Bank of America needs a chat bot that
bought needs to understand things like
checking account and money market
account but if Home Depot wants to build
a chat bot they bought needs to
understand things like backsplash
workshop and half-inch drywall screws
completely different vocabulary
completely different semantics so if you
want to build a chat bot here are some
skills that you need to know you need to
have some idea about what architectures
are present some NLP expertise syntax
and semantics keyword extraction topic
modeling question answering a few of
them which would help you understand the
next steps of what to do machine
learning classification and clustering
at a very minimum
and finally coming back to the
architecture of the chat pod we talked
about all of these and the last one once
you know what needs to be done how do
you present a response to was
responsible to the user that's an
important question
the ideal approaches well you generate
this beautiful text that the chat bar
automatically creates and you present it
to the user and so you break down the
sentence into individual components form
a new sentence that's intact eclis
correct what state of art is invariant
and you can see that if you look at
Google Translate often when you
translate from language one to language
to language two feels like it was
generated automatically and it doesn't
quite convey what what a human would say
so if you it's a choice that you need to
make that you would you be comfortable
with grammatical simple grammatical
errors where the sentence is created by
a bot or you can use a template template
based system which is what Siri and
Alexa and all of these other systems are
using right now where you have this
template and several versions of this
template which says things like your
order number blank was delivered to
blank at blank time thank you for
shopping with us and the same thing is
template is used for anybody who's
asking about a specific order and they
just replace these blanks with the the
actual information what Siri does is it
has a large variety of ways in which it
conveys this information so when you ask
the same question repeatedly again and
again it does not you do not get bored
because you get a large variety of
answers so that brings me to the end of
the talk where our chat bots going from
here all leading verticals have begun to
use chat BOTS several different
financial institutions have released new
chat BOTS Macy's has one with which they
work with will IBM Watson we are able to
outsource a lot of mundane and
repetitive tasks and I think that's a
huge advantage to do and I'd love to
hear your thoughts about what you think
you can do with chat BOTS
and that's it thank you so much thank
you very much again that you want to
reach us on Twitter it is at PI data
Seattle and I can take questions on
Twitter or from the audience so you
covered that all the major verticals
have chat bots all right right now do
you see any special purpose chat bots or
he really kept us making a leap beyond
what they currently do with simple
answers I think there's a huge potential
for chat BOTS they will be making a leap
maybe sometime in the next five to ten
years we are definitely not there yet
due to several considerations but one
other thing that I wanted to point out
as things like health care or suicide
lines where people are not available at
different times of the night to help
other people to talk through their
problems or there are people who are
waiting in line to talk to specialists
and if we have these BOTS that can ask
ask questions or if we have these BOTS I
can
you know recommend resources it would
help significantly to to in the
healthcare department not just one I
mean there's so many like Finance which
what would be beneficial yes
gender a good question so we're the kind
of metrics do you evaluate chatbots do
you mean successful list of chatbots
or so how do we measure how do we
measure successes of building the
chatbot itself how successful as the
chatbot is it's conversations so how do
you evaluate at bottom go in this
question a lot and there's no one answer
for it if you do search based if you're
sad body is doing search based things
like FAQ you know how search is
evaluated you know you need precision
and you need recall and you need F score
and you're done but it's an bots there
is a it's much more complicated because
you want to know how the human is
receiving something receiving a response
you want to know whether they will came
back to you the chat bar or the next
time around they wanted to use some
other interface and this is just the
human interface aspect in the training
aspect based on their training data if
you have some kind of a classification
approach where given statement a your
philosophy class assigning it into a
calendar operation versus a scheduling
operation you can use the same metrics
that you use for any classification
machine learning tasks and and that
should work so at the end of it you want
to break down the complexity of your
tasks into individual evaluation systems
and test each individual system and
together if your is kind of simulating a
human being you know it's hard to
evaluate a human being in this evaluate
different aspects of them like
especially very smart and what this
version doesn't know about leaking of
faucets but this person knows about
something else so it's you have to break
it down to do the evaluation so Boris on
the Twitter asks how is the output logic
for the best buy or real estate bot
generated from the training data the
best buy bot and the real estate bot are
two separate but the best I bought was
trained on the FAQ I believe of Best Buy
and the real estate Bart was for that
real estate company and on their own
data so it supposed to be like most of
these bots are
fairly special purpose you're going to
be training mostly on your own unique
data sets yes there are a large number
of generic but but you know if I ask you
today which parts are your favorite
parts you'd be like yeah I don't think
anybody has a favorite bar because most
of them are very generic it's only the
specialized parts which help you with
your day-to-day that you remember and
that you want to use again and again I
want to you know spend through here like
a couple guys on the fence we are you
and planet one robot and they have to
decide between you know adopting one of
the ethnic a let's say for a book on
life or they expect you know low-level
AI on axiomatic networking and a
beautiful sketch so do you think a you
know that need to be use anyway and we
will Matt but like you know IVF before
we make the Mallory it was so the SDKs
that are available right now are trained
on data that's freely available right
now
so Google News for instance is one where
that news is available the text is
available classifications are available
so you can scrape that news for maybe a
year and train your model or Wikipedia
or several other corpora now if you're
building your bot for something much
more specialized like maybe something
internal to Microsoft because we're in
Microsoft maybe sub something about how
some how the buildings are structured or
what are the plans for the future and
things like that you want to have your
board trained on that proprietary data
and when you get into that level of
customization off-the-shelf API is don't
seem to work they would work on very
generic cases only so at that in that
case you want to build your own semantic
network your own training your own
modules and build out a bot we have
another good question from Jiang on
Twitter are there any BOTS or SDKs etc
that you have recently read that have
the capacity for the bot to actually
learn a new procedure or a new method
that's an interesting question
well there's a lot of research in that
area for computers to learn our systems
to learn new tasks and new functionality
I don't think it has come in to the bot
space yet but it has come into teaching
robots to trust human beings and a bunch
of other things but it's it's it's in a
very research intensive intensive phase
right now thank you very much thank you
ladies and gentlemen we're wrapping up a
little early because we do have to clear
this room and get it turned over so that
we can have entertainment and food in
here shortly I remind you that coming up
soon is the PI data
well the hub trivia contest over in
Kodiak and we'll be back here again
after 6:20 thank you very much
[Music]
[Applause]